翻訳: Keiko Ishigami
校正: Kayoko Shiomi
僕は 日本とアフリカなど世界中の子供達を
ダンスとインターネット中継で繋いでいます
今まで22か国1万5千人以上の子供達に
ダンスを教えて
そのうち 3千人以上の子供達を
繋いできました
ただ 中々想像がつかないと思うので
まずは写真を見ていただければと思います
この写真は ウガンダ エチオピア
日本の子供達です
日本とウガンダ 日本とエチオピアなど
中継で繋いで 一緒にダンスを踊るんです
日本とアフリカの子供を
繋ぐことが多いのですが
ベトナムやカンボジアなど
アジアの国々の子供達も繋いでいます
一緒にダンスを踊ることで
国や文化や言語の違いを越えて
とても仲良くなるんです
みんな楽しそうですよね
僕が今日 みなさんにお伝えしたい
メッセージは一つだけです
それは「やりたいことを口に出そう」
ということです
「そんなの恥ずかしい」とか
「口に出したところで何が変わるんだ」
と言う人もいるかもしれません
でも やりたいことを口に出したら
僕の人生は大きく変わりました
今日は そんなお話をしたいと思います
これは
（笑）
僕の写真なんですけどね
これは 小学生時代 高校生時代
大学生時代の僕の写真です
変化がありますかね？
今は全国 海外を飛び回っているので
活動的な人だと思われることが多いのですが
元々は 全然行動力がなかったし
やりたいことに
全然チャレンジできない人でした
自分に自信がなかったし
コンプレックスだらけだったんです
だから この写真に写っている頃の僕たちは
すごい内気な頃の僕です
もともと 兄と比較して
ずっと劣等感を抱えていました
僕は 兄より成績も低かったし
兄が通っていた学校にも落ちて通えなかったし
スポーツもダメでした
ダンスも 兄の影響で始めました
兄がやっていたから カッコいいなと思って
僕も高校生のときにダンスを始めました
大学に入ってもダンス漬けの毎日
熱中するものがあっても
あいかわらず自分に自信はありませんでした
まわりとの人間関係もうまくいかず
高校生の時にいじめられていた経験から
周りの人を
全然信用することができませんでした
人と接するのが本当に怖かったんです
ただ 毎日同じ場所で
ダンスの練習をしていくうちに
だんだんとこう仲良くなってきて
だまされてもいいからもっと仲良くなりたいな
そんな気持ちが芽生えてきて
少しずつ 少しずつ
変わっていくことができました
また 大学の先輩の紹介もあって
キッズダンス教室でダンスの講師もしました
とっても楽しかったです
そんなダンス漬けの大学生活を送っていました
そんな大学生活だったのですが
漠然とした夢も持っていました
世界一周がしたかったんです
広い世界を見てみたいな と思っていたし
何か大きなことをしたい
そんなふうに思って
世界一周に憧れていたのですが
大学生の時は 行けませんでした
怖かったんです
僕が世界一周なんて無理だ
というふうに思っていた理由は 3つあります
まずは 英語ができない と思っていたこと
大学の学年で僕はビリの成績でした
もう本当に英語ができなかったんです
英語がとにかく怖くて 海外の人と
コミュニケーションをとるなんて無理だ
そんなふうに思っていました
そして2つ目は お腹が弱いこと
（笑）
本当にお腹が弱いんですけど
お腹が弱い僕が
海外の過酷な環境で過ごすなんてできない
そんなふうに思っていました
そして3つ目は 海外が怖い
海外に行くの怖いな
そんなふうに思っていました
もともと何か新しいことに
チャレンジをしたことがなかった僕は
そもそも 何か新しいことに
挑戦すること自体に恐怖を感じていました
そんな僕は世界一周に憧れていたけど行けず
留学にも憧れていたけど行けず
大学生活をそのまま終えて
会社に就職し 働き始めました
会社員になって社会人として働き始めてからも
学生時代の時にダンスを教えていた生徒や
その保護者の人達から
「またダンスを教えてください」
そんなふうに言われたんですけど
「やりたいけど 忙しいのでできません」
そんなふうに言って断っていました
でも 忙しいというのは
ただの言い訳だったんですね
本心としては すごい怖かったんです
僕はこう何か 自分で人を集めて
会を実施するということを
一切やったことがなかったので
自信がありませんでした
すごい怖かったんです
ただ 社会人の4年目の時に転機が訪れました
たまたま参加した教育関係の交流会でした
その時に
ついポロっと言ってしまったんです
「ダンスを教えたいと思ってるんですけどね」
そんなふうに言ってしまったんです
教育に関心のある人って
熱い人が多いんですよ
（笑）
みんなキラーンて こう目が輝いてですね
「やってみたらいいじゃん やってみなよ」
そんなふうに背中を押されました
「やらない理由がないじゃん」って
言われました
「公民館借りたらいいし
週末にちょっと時間を作ったらいいし
声かけてくれてる子供たちや保護者の人たちに
手伝ってもらったらいいじゃん
一度回やってみなよ」そんなふうに
グイグイグイグイ背中を押されました
そして僕は 会社員として働きながら
週末にボランティアで
また子供たちにダンスを教え始めました
20人以上の子供たちが集まってくれて
レッスンは大成功でした
本当に幸せな体験でした
やりたいことを口に出して
いろんな人が手伝ってくれて
一緒にハッピーな場を作ることができるんだ
そんなふうに思えた初めての経験でした
人からしたら小さなことかもしれないですけど
僕にとっては大きな経験でした
「やりたいことってできるんだ
やりたいことを先延ばしにするのをやめよう」
そんなふうに思いました
もうレッスンが終わって帰りの電車でも
胸の内側がすごい震えているんですね
「わあ なんて幸せなんだろう
やりたいことってできるんだ」
そんなふうに思いました
そして家に帰ると 家の壁には
学生時代のころに書いた「世界一周する」
という紙が貼ってあったんですね
学生のころからずっと貼ってたんですよ
「世界一周って 一生のうちで
いつかできたらいいなと思ってたけど
これって今すぐできるんだ」
そんなふうに思いました
もう迷いはありませんでした
４年間働いた会社を辞めて
夢だった世界一周に出発しました
大好きだったダンスを教えながら
世界中をまわることにしたんです
旅前も旅中も やりたいことを口に出したら
ステキな出会いがたくさんありました
僕にとっては 初めての海外一人旅が
世界一周だったんです
（笑）
だから旅のことを全然知らなかったんですね
無謀だとかよく言われるんですけど
ただ「ダンスを教えながら
世界一周したいんです」って
出会う人出会う人に言い続けて
SNSで書いたり
ブログで書いたりしているうちに
旅人を紹介してくれたり
海外でも子供に関わっている人を
紹介してくれたりしました
英語が本当に怖かったので 最初の２か月間は
フィリピンに留学に行きました
語学留学をしました
この時に学んだのは
単語や文法ももちろん大切だけど
それ以上に「自分のことを伝えたい」
という気持ちだったり
「相手のことを知りたい」そういう気持ちが
一番大事なんだなってことを知りました
また やりたいことに
一歩踏み出すのに出遅れてしまった
そんなふうに思っていた僕に
フィリピン人の先生は
「全部最適なタイミングでやってくるんだよ
だから あなたにとっては
今がベストタイミングなんだよ」
そんなふうに言ってくれました
今もその言葉をすごく大事にしています
いざ出発した世界一周は
本当にステキな出会いがたくさんあって
まさしく自分にとって
ベストなタイミングでした
最初にフィリピンの語学学校に行った時も
「ダンスを教えたいんです」って
いろんな人に言っていたら
その語学学校の売店のスタッフさんが
近所の子供たちを集めてくれて
すごい楽しかったです
アフリカのマラウイでも
「ダンスを教えたいんです」って言ったら
村中の人たちが手伝ってくれて—
すごいですよね—
2,000人の子供たちと一緒に
ダンスフェスティバルを開催しました
（笑）
もうこの学校とか 僕はバスで10時間くらい
揺られて行った村なんですけど
お腹とか痛くなりながらね
行ったんですけど
そしたら村の人たちが歓迎してくれて
みんな手伝ってくれました
そんなマラウイの映像があるので
ちょっと動画を見てほしいなと思います
[アフリカの温かい心 マラウィ]
（音楽）
（拍手）
ありがとうございます
本当に楽しかったです
子供たちもすごい楽しんでくれました
いろんな人が手伝ってくれて
感謝までされてしまいました
僕がやりたいと言って始めたことなのにです
国や言葉や文化の違いを超えて
世界中に友達ができました
もともと僕は人とが怖いと思っていたんです
なのに 世界中に友だちができました
自分の人生がすごい豊かになったな
そんなふうに感じました
自分の価値観も世界観が大きく広がりました
ダンスでの交流を通して
自分に自信もつきました
みんなそれぞれ
自分だけの価値を持っているんだな
そんなふうに思うようになりました
２歳の小さい子も
おじいちゃんおばあちゃんも
みんなカッコいいダンスを踊るんですよね
誰を見ても
「うわ すごいカッコいいな」と思ったし
みんなも僕のことを素直に認めてくれるんです
ああ 一人一人が
その人だけの価値を持っているんだ
そんなふうに思うようになりました
そんなふうに変化していった僕なんですが
もともとは 会社員の時に
「ダンスを教えたいと思ってるんですけどね」
そんなふうに言ってしまったことから
すべては始まりました
世界一周を終えて 自分のような経験を
いろんな子供たちにも経験して欲しい
そんなふうに思うようになりました
子供たちの可能性や世界も大きく広げたい
世界中の子供たちも友だちになって欲しいな
そんなふうに思うようになりました
だから帰国後は 自分のダンス教室を始めて
日本中や世界中を飛び回りながら
世界中の子供たちをダンスと
インターネット中継で繋げる活動をしています
今後は いろんな世代の人が集まって
一緒に学び合える
そんな地域の場を作りたいなと思っています
ダンスやインターネットは
僕にとってあくまでツールで
僕の目的は 子供たちの世界や
可能性を広げたいな ということだったり
自分に自信をもってもらいたいな
そんなことが目的です
子供だけに限らず
いろんな人の背中を押したい
そんな風に思っています
なぜなら 僕自身が
背中をいっぱい押されたことで
一歩踏み出すことができて
自分の人生が大きく変わったからです
怖くてもいいんです
怖いけどやりたいことこそ
本当にやりたいことなんだと思います
やりたいことからは逃げられません
やり方なんて 動き出さなきゃ分かりません
僕の場合は やりたいことを口に出したら
いろんな人が協力してくれて
一緒にハッピーな場を作ることができました
もしかしたら反対する人もいるかもしれません
でも 自分の人生の責任を取れるのは
自分だけです
誰かが 自分の責任を取ってくれる
わけではありません
だから 自分で決断して行動することが
大事なんだと思っています
僕の場合は やりたいことを口に出して
一歩踏み出すことができました
もしみなさんが
何か新しい一歩を踏み出したい
そんなふうに思っていたら
やりたいことを 是非口に出してみてください
そうすることが 人生が大きく広がる
最初の一歩になるんだと思います
そうやって みんなが自分の大好きなことを
やっていける世界になったらいいな
そんなふうに思っています
ありがとうございました
(拍手)